alright went out to the union between
duchesses we've heard all about Caitlyn
making so called family feud but today
new details about their Royal pact
we actually saw Kate kiss Megan hello
then when they greeted each other there
was a really really warm energy between
the two of them
yesterday's cheek smooch between the two
made headlines but was it all for show
the Duchess's have reportedly made a
private pact between them to be cordial
to each other in public and I understand
that both of them have sort of agreed
that you know for the sake of
appearances they they really want it to
look as if they get on they both realize
that the idea of a feud you know a royal
cat fight between two duchesses doesn't
help any of them the two were aware of
reports of a feud and are said to have
wanted to put on a public show
friendliness they don't seem to dislike
each other but are not that close at the
moment they're still living very close
to each other at Kensington Palace they
really are just across a courtyard and
apparently they've been in text hatch I
think occasionally Kate invites Megan
over for tea but they haven't had a
hugely close relationship
yesterday's Commonwealth Day service
marked Megan's last official engagement
before she delivers her baby
so as Megan prepares to put her feet up
it really feels like Kate is now using
this as her chance to take center stage
we saw her out today visiting a
Children's Centre that was a Duchess
that said I mean business and that's
what she's getting down to
[Music]
[Applause]